c'est un procès très médiatisé qui
s'ouvrira dans moins de 10 jours celui
du lanceur d'alert le plus célèbre de la
planète
détenu à la prison de belmarsh dans la
banlieue de londres
un procès dont l'enjeu est de transférer
julian assange
washington semble plus que jamais
déterminés à obtenir de la justice
britannique
l'extradition du lanceur d' alerte si
tel était le verdict le fondateur de
wikileaks devra faire face aux états
unis à 18 chefs d'inculpation qui
concernent entre autres la révélation de
700 mille documents classés secret
militaire notamment concernant l'irak et
l'afghanistan
le fait d'avoir aidé et incité chelsea
meaning l'ex analyste militaire à
obtenir des documents mais aussi la mise
en danger des sources opérant pour le
gouvernement américain
des accusations que l'intéressé et ses
soutiens justifie par la volonté des
états unis de détruire la presse libre
et des soutiens du lan assange n'en
manque pas depuis le début de la faire
partout dans le monde
des protestataires se mobilisent pour
demander sa libération
beaucoup n'ont pas hésité à faire le
voyage en février dernier pour marquer
leur opposition à cette détention qu'il
juge abusive et dénoncer les agissements
du gouvernement américain mais ils
devraient être moins nombreux devant le
tribunal londonien en septembre prochain
en effet pour lutter contre le coc vie
19 le royaume-uni a décidé d'imposer une
14/n d'isolement obligatoire à toute
personne venant de france
kovy 19 ou pas les soutiens d'assange ne
baisse pas les bras
le gouvernement britannique reçoit en
effet régulièrement des demandes de
libération des quatre coins du globe
le collectif de 216 médecin ou encore le
collectif 250 juristes et avocats 40
organisations internationales de défense
des droits
reporters sans frontières mais également
l'association française robin des lois
autre motif d'inquiétude pour les
soutiens de julian assange la santé du
lanceur d' alerte qui se dégrade de jour
en jour en témoigne le récit de sa
compagne stella morice à l'issue d'une
visite ils portaient un brassard jaune
pour indiquer son niveau de statut de
prisonnier et on pouvait voir à quel
point ses bras étaient fin au moins il a
pu voir les enfants même s'ils ne
pouvaient pas les toucher les enfants
étaient tous les deux calme nous sommes
tous
rester assis tout le temps ils souffrent
beaucoup côté français on s'organise
comme on peut pour alerter les pouvoirs
publics objectifs des soutiens français
du lanceur dallaire obtenir l'asile
politique pour julian assange
malgré le silence de l'exécutif sur ce
dossier ils ne perdent pas espoir et
pour cause le nouveau garde des sceaux
n'est autre qu' eric dupond moretti
l'ancien avocat de julian assange en
février dernier l'ex ténor du barreau
avait solennellement appelé à ce que la
france accorde l'asile aux lanceurs
d'alert les 175 ans de prison qu'on lui
promet aux états unis c'est une peine
indignes insupportables et contraire à
l'idée que l'on peut tous se faire des
droits de l'homme l'asile politique pour
le lanceur d'alert la seule issue
capable de contrecarrer la demande
d'extradition selon l'association
française robin des lois si un pays
européens accordent aujourd'hui l'asile
à julian assange la protection
subsidiaire s'appliquer les autorités
britanniques ne pourront pas l'extrader
même si le tribunal de londres lors
donné le procès qui s'ouvre le 7
septembre prochain doit durer trois
jours trois jours durant lesquels les
avocats de julian assange se relaieront
à la barre pour expliquer que les états
unis cherche à museler la liberté de la
presse et de faire de julian assange
un prisonnier politique s'il est extradé
le lanceur d'alert australien et risque
jusqu'à 175 années de prison